I'm going to be meeting two different breast surgeons in the coming weeks and want to be prepared with good questions.
I want to avoid problems or complications later if I do have surgery.
I don't know what to look out for or what to request so that I may be discerning and choose the right person or team any advice.
That's really hard. You have to just feel comfortable with your surgeon, surgeon number one.
So I always suggest that you do have a meeting or two with that with him or her and that you feel comfortable.
You should be praying about that and get asked that God gives you discernment in this.
There are any really specific questions that I can think of or things to look for in that.
It's really whether they're hopeful and they feel like they're honest with you.
You don't want to do surgery just because that's the thing that they do at this point.
You want to do surgery because it's the right thing for you.
And you want a surgeon that thinks that too so that they look at your case and look at your CT scanner MRI or anything and they say,
yeah, I think this is what we're going to do.
I think this is going to be really good.
Ask, you know, there's nothing wrong with asking, what would you do if this was your sister?
You know, what would you do if this is your wife or your your friend, your best friend?
Could you please be just honest with me and ask of that question.
Please really be honest with me and see if you get a heartfelt honest answer.
So that's what I would do.